there's no justice they shower their
arms locked climate activists from
across Europe gathered in the small
village of luzarat determined to prevent
the neighboring coal mine from expanding
with all legal means exhausted police
start removing activists from blocking
the road the initial operation to clear
access to the site begins relatively
peaceful what has brought you to little
Hut yeah we have an energy crisis we
have global warming so
I think it's worth
thank you
but then police start to move forward
more forcefully the mood turns Grim with
police and activists now clashing
[Applause]
there's a real fight now between the
activists and police here at the Village
of luxura police was trying to push
forward toward the village to affect it
but now activists are really trying to
push them away and you can see there's a
real scuffle going on here behind me
workers from the Energy company rwe who
operate the gas Weiler opencast mine
immediately start to clear the
barricades
the climate Ministry did not want to
speak on camera a spokesman explained
that more coal is needed to ensure
security of Supply but that the
government will phase out coal
completely in eight years from now this
can't go any further we know that we
don't need the coal under lots of art
for energy safety and it needs to stay
in the ground for climate Justice
bullies are calling in reinforcements
from all over Germany for the main
eviction operation one they described as
complex and dangerous
we have three houses of 10 meters high
and even higher we need Specialists to
remove these occupiers without
endangering anyone we are assigned to
legally and consequently prosecute any
offenders and we have been ordered to
clear this location and we shall do that
the police say they will aim to avoid
using violence but only if the activists
remain peaceful protesters have built a
system of observation posts around the
site I'm afraid I'm scared all the time
a little a bit some some sometimes more
sometimes less when the cups are coming
I'm super scared and I know how they act
and how they force people to do what
they want
police say the main operation to clear
the protest Camp itself is expected to
take several weeks step fast and Al
Jazeera in luzarat